Hey, what's going on it's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and ahhh.
Just checking in on you. I'm just
checking in on you. How are Ya?
How's it going? I'm actually doing great
despite the, uh, that cough I just did.
There wasn't a real cough. I
just, you know, I've, I've,
I've run out of unique ways to
say I'm just checking in on you.
I try to do it a little bit
differently and I, I got nothing left.
I don't know what you want from
me. Um, anyway, so let's get on.
Let's get on with the podcast here.
You know, this is just a quick one.
This isn't even an official podcast,
despite the fact that I have
fucking advertising on it.
It's not an official one.
That's just me just poking my head
into a little office into your little
cubicle, any living room, if
you're unemployed or maybe a,
you're living off a trust.
Yeah,
it's a great big shout out to anybody
just sitting around living off a trust,
you know, when are you going to do
today? I go down to the art store,
get yourself an Easel, you know,
little canvas, dark painting.
That's what people do. You know
when you're like super fucking rich,
there's no reason for you to go outside
the business. No fucking reason. And I,
I really can't stand when people judge,
you know,
trust fund babies.
I feel that's like one of the,
one of the biggest issues that this
country is dealing with right now.
We see harsh judgment of
trust fund babies, you know,
I mean anybody can be
fucking broke and be like,
look at that rich conscious sitting
over there doing nothing. What a waste.
What a waste of a fucking life.
You know? Let me tell you this.
She was subway sandwich, eating
judgmental. Fuck. Let me ask you this.
If you were in that situation,
what would you be doing?
Cause I could tell you what I would be
doing the exact same fucking thing and
all you fucking people on your high horse.
No Dude, I could do it. You know
I one of those people, you know,
people know that people know me.
I have to wake up with a purpose.
If I don't have a purpose in life,
shut the fuck up your bills.
All right?
That's what you're doing and you're
walking out the door and you chasing the
fucking Keratin. Someday you're
dreaming it. Dream that that care,
it's not going to be there. You want
to be that easeful guy. You know?
Look at George Bush,
man.
Do you ever see a guy enjoying not
being president more than that guy?
He's actually good at what he does. He's
not a trust fund baby either, by the way.
I'm just saying,
you know he's actually good at it.
Just sits there.
I wonder what he thinks about just,
there's no way to be present
when you leave as president,
you have dead bodies on your conscience
or the you made the right decision or
the wrong decision.
At some point you add to shoot off
some missiles because who's kidding?
Who America is the world's babysitter.
Okay.
We know what we know what's best for you.
Okay,
and what is best for you is to do what
we say and give us your natural resources
as we pretend to care about your people.
Okay?
It's like a lifetime movie.
Everybody's acting like
something special's happening
at the end of the day was
wasn't that really just a bunch of
shit so you could fucking make money?
Isn't that what it was?
I have no idea what I'm talking about.
I'm talking about trust fund babies
and I'm sick of the judgment of a boot
judges a baby, first of all,
kind of a fucking person.
You maybe that's why God didn't give
you money. You have to think about that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's called Karma.
Isn't that the most overused
working expression Karma?
This is my theory on Karma.
Karma gets you. Unless you,
unless you don't give a fuck.
If you don't give a fuck and you don't,
if you truly don't give a shit,
you got to have like a level of guilt
for common to come back and bite you in
the ass. But if you just some fucking
entitled con you, those people,
they'd skate through life.
You know, you ever see him,
you ever seen entitled can
just walk across the room.
It's like he has those little kids
shoes on and have the wheels on them.
You know, I take two steps.
They just glide across the room.
They don't care about breaking hearts.
They don't care about evicting people.
All right?
They don't give a shit who fucking
sewed their shirt together that out.
What does that endangered species
throw it on the grill. They don't care.
You know, there's a genius to that. Just
not giving a shit. You know what I mean?
I'd love to see one of those people,
you know,
in the afterlife if you have to get,
if you actually get judged just to
see the fucking look in the face,
you know what I mean?
And then God at some point would have
to feel some sort of shame being like,
well, you know, at the end of the day
I assembled that. You know what I mean?
That's why I've never understood about
the judgment. It's just like, you know,
especially with these fucking sociopath's
as opposed to the levelheaded saint
that I am, these fucking, these
fucking sociopath's out there.
Like, where does, you
know, shouldn't you know,
shouldn't you be judging God on that one?
Gingy be looking up like really,
you know,
what are you doing blow last night?
Yeah.
You forgot to put the A, I give a shit
about other people assembly into this one
just fucking senate out there.
I don't know. The more I,
I vaguely pay attention to
all that space shit. You know,
I hate people who are in
this space by the way.
There was talking about do you
understand and you can keep looking.
It's like, yes. Yeah, I
get it. I get it. You don't
understand. Is We fucking, we've,
we've, we've seen how gigantic it
is yet. We haven't found anything.
So I still think this
place is pretty amazing.
Is Fascinating as Mars is.
There's this nothing to do.
I don't understand these fucking people
that want to go to Mars and live there
and it's like,
and do what?
Huh?
Living some fucking strip mall
for the rest of your life.
Some star trek looking strip mall.
Yeah.
Fucking drinking Tang just so
you can say, Oh yeah, you know,
that's your big fucking move that,
you know, people want to live on Mars.
That means they suck at everything else
in life. Right? They got enough of that.
You know? You know what it
is. You graduate high school,
you want to come back someday,
right? Smoking a big cigar going,
hey, you know, yeah, I was at guy
used to push around the playground,
but you know what I did
right? I went, I did things,
I did digs and now I smoke this and
I drive that and see that over there.
That's fucking me admitted. I matter.
So usually in this day and age, that means
you're going to try to create an APP,
right? You've got no Fuckin, I
don't know, get some sort of,
you start a website,
will you curate videos and fucking news?
I don't know what these fucking
millennials do, but I think if you,
if you suck at that, right?
You can't play an instrument
and you ego cannot just handle just
being happy with what you have.
I think at that point it's like I can't
just go back to my high school reunion,
just being in some regular Joe
Waking up in the morning,
putting my coffee in, my thermos,
going into the shower and quietly crying
was the water cascades over my face and
my wife comes walking and going to Uri
just be like, yeah, it just, I was,
I just sneezed. I'm fine.
Just washing my face.
All right.
I think at some point,
either you just fucking given
and just say, hey man, you
know, being a regular guy,
he's kind of fucking cool, you
know, or you can't handle it.
Right. They should mind me.
I'd never seen a few good men.
You get hurdle the truth,
you know, there's too many,
too much gritten a teeth in that
movie. That's right. Ice Man.
I am dangerous. Right. Too much of that
shit. So I never watched it. You know,
which people walking around
dressed in fucking then
little navy suits. Um, anyways,
he can't fucking handle it and you
got to go back to your high school,
you and you're got to do something.
And I think at that point,
that's when you just say, listen,
I, I, I got to live on Mars.
I mean, I can't go back with nothing.
I got to have something to say.
That's like Lance Bass,
he couldn't handle that.
Justin Timberlake walked away from,
from in sync.
Right.
Ah,
want it that way or whatever
the fuck they sing that song.
They all acted like puppets.
Right. He just fucking walked away,
you know, and got the
one guy, the goatee guy,
he's got a sense of humor about himself.
He makes all these funny commercials.
He'll do a thing. He doesn't give a fuck.
Right. You've got the dreadlock guy.
Then he used to bang Jennifer Aniston.
Or was that the other guy who,
some white guy with dreadlocks used to
go out with Jennifer Aniston, you know,
every be one of those beautiful
celebrities always dates a guy.
And he always have that, that, that
really, you got that moment like, wow,
why didn't I learn how to right fucking
play the Ukulele and wear flip flops?
That's what I had to do. Fucking walking
around with your goddamn man tits. Um,
anyway, sorry. And I think Lance
Gonadal, he's just like, what the fuck,
you know, so then annexing, you know,
he's signing up to go out and
space to somehow try and outdo, oh,
what'd you put you put out
future sexy songs? Huh? Wait,
wait, wait. Right, wait,
wait, wait, wait man.
I'm going to outer space.
What?
Oh, what is it about wearing your pajamas
in the middle of the day? That just,
it just fucking opens your mind up.
You know what I mean? I swear to God
there is no free of feeling
that being a white male,
heterosexual still in your pajamas at
11 o'clock in the morning on a weekday,
on a weekday. And you know what,
cause I'm a liberal country,
I want everyone to experience that,
you know,
all the people in the Philippines.
Um,
anyways, uh, I'm actually,
I'm in a giddy mood cause I did something
yesterday that scared the living shit
out of me and I didn't die,
which is all, you know,
obviously cause I'm doing
this podcast. So, you know,
I hadn't flown a helicopter, uh,
since like October until this month.
And I flew for the first time and I could
not believe how fucking rusty I was.
How much? Just Shit. You forget.
You're like, what? Oh yeah. Oh yeah.
Oh yeah, that's right. You know,
turn a bass tournament final.
I didn't even slow down.
I was so busy trying to keep the fucking
pad between the compass, you know?
And the dashboard day I came out with
the fuck called the control panel that I
forgot I was still doing like 65
knots and I fucking went right by it.
I had to slam on the brakes. Right.
So, but you know, I flew around,
she'll kick off the Russia, he's coming
around, it's coming around, you know.
So I went,
I went again yesterday and uh,
went up with my instructor and he was
like, so what do you want to do? I said,
all right, let's do the pattern.
Let's fly the traffic pattern.
Let's do some auto sets where they
simulate a main road of failure.
That's the big fan above your head.
Like,
what if all of a sudden the
engine cuts up, you know, um,
and then those kicks left. What do you
do? You slammed the collective down ad,
right pedal, right trim, air speed,
rpm. Here come the rpms coming up,
you pull the collective up, he
catch fucking things, you pick
up your spot. So we were doing those and
at some point I was just like, all right,
fuck this. Okay. Um, I,
I have to fly this thing by myself
or solo is they saying the business,
but I'm just a novice. So I said,
all right. He goes, well, okay,
we did a couple of those. He goes, what
do you want to do now? I said, all right,
can,
uh,
can you just step out and let me just
fly this thing around one time by myself
just to do it again? And
he goes, yeah, absolutely.
So he steps out and up to that point,
it's been a great day. You know,
not a lot of traffic over there.
Everything's fucking fine. So he gets out,
roll it back up. You know, lights are out,
our PM's are in the green gauges.
Roe, green cabaret heats up.
I fucking lift up light on the skids,
bring it up, bump, holding a hover.
Here we go. Here we go. Cyclic.
Wait for it. Wait for it.
Less weight in the fucking,
yeah, thank you. No
fucking palms are sweating.
You know there's always said done.
I can't believe I actually fucking
know how to do this thing right.
So immediately there's a
fucking crosswind. So I'm
looking at the wind sock. Oh,
you fucking content. Fight it. Left
pedal. Now I'm facing the winds.
Everything's fine.
And next thing you know,
like fucking like three jet blue's
are taken off at southwest is landing.
You know, I made my call and the
guy's like, you know, whatever,
fucking six Victor Hotel, stand by,
stand by means shut the fuck up.
I always forget that.
Cause then I would go six tricks
through hotels standing by.
So I'm fucking sitting there. I felt
like I was in a harbor for 20 minutes.
What I really wanted to have happen.
It was just like one of those things
where it's like, all right, fuck this up,
fill in this rolled out, have him
step out. I fucking roll back up,
lifted off.
As for clarity,
gives it to me and I just take
it for a lap around the airport.
That's all I wanted to do.
So now I'm fucking sitting
in this Harvard just going,
Jesus Christ.
Now I'm thinking,
what the fuck am I doing?
So finally he called, yeah, go fuck go.
Six Victor Hotel. I left closed
traffic. I've cleared for takeoff cliff,
take off six Victor Hotel. And
then I uh, I fucking took off,
brought it around and when I was
turning across, when you know,
I'm looking for traffic,
did join the downwind,
make sure I don't have any problems. I
was actually thinking like, you know,
last night I did stand up dressed is
Steven Adler at the goddamn comedy jam.
I tried out a new fucking bit about
blow up dolls that was killing so hard.
I looked over and Josh,
Adam Meyers was fucking die in laughing
on the side of the stage. It's so,
as much as you make people laugh,
when you look over and you see a
fellow comedian dying laughing,
you know you're onto something. So then
I went back and I got to play rhinos,
sore dressed as Steven Adler sound,
the sound guy.
Now I would have dressed up as Matt
camera, but he's just, you know,
he doesn't have any unique facial hair.
He's got that sorted out. Luke haircut.
I just want to look like me with
this stupid wig on, you know? Um,
and then I got to play the encore
paradise city and I was thinking,
I fucking did that. I did stand
up and play drums live last night.
It right now I'm flying
a helicopter by myself
and I flunked so much shit in high school,
terrible at math,
fucking flood French,
all of that shit
was a great feeling. And I was
like, Oh yeah, that's right.
I'm flying a helicopter.
So I get to the downwind, you know,
red, you go across three zero,
you bring your fucking carburetor heat up.
See if you're fucking carburetor.
Doesn't freeze over in the engine,
doesn't cut out as you slowing down.
Came around,
still pulling power kit,
my 60 knots as I turned the
fucking base in the file.
K right in layette.
Set that thing down nicely.
And uh, they're, my instructor
came back in and just, you know,
plugs his headphones in. He goes,
he goes, uh, how did that feel?
I said, hey, you know, I said it was like
riding a bike except you could kill you
self.
I started laughing.
And what I've found with instructors
is they're all bad ass guys.
Every one of them chicks, they're
all fucking bad assets, you know.
But the second you admit that you're
actually scared, they always laugh.
And then they usually tell you a story
how fucking nervous that they weren't.
But if you have some fucking cocky cunt,
um,
you don't want to do that.
Cause then what they're
gonna do is they're going to
chop throttle on you as you
fucking doing some stuff here.
And I don't need that,
even though it's good training. I've
never had anybody do that to me. Um,
but anyways,
so I did it and it made me
feel a fucking amazing man,
just like the sickest goddamn feeling.
And I swear to God,
all I need to do is make
like another $40 million.
And I think I could actually afford
to truly engage in that hobby.
I in La,
it's just super expensive.
I think if you live more
in the middle of nowhere,
the big fucking thing is like just
storing the goddamn whatever you get the
plane or the helicopter.
Um,
I don't know if anybody knows like a
cheap way to do it. I would absolutely,
uh, absolutely do it. But until then,
I'm just treating it like the way I
treat cars. Like I just go on the road,
you know, I go to budget
and then that's it. I just,
whatever fucking car they give me, I get
it. And I gotta be honest with you. I,
that's the one thing that bugs
me about renting helicopters.
And every time you fucking go in there,
eh, something's a little different.
You know, just be nice to
know you fucking tail number.
Not have to fucking constantly
be looking on the control panel.
Know where everything is,
know how everything works.
Every radio seems to be a little bit
different. It's just like a fucking,
it's just that extra thing.
You got to like deal with it.
I wish I didn't and I'd love to just
buy one of those fucking are 20 twos.
You know, they're funny as hell. They
just a little to cdot, right? Any,
you're really flying it.
It's like if you had a car that just
had drum brakes and no power steering,
like you really fucking,
you know, are holding up.
This is just what I've heard from other
pilots cause I've never flown anything
fancy, nothing fancy. Like, um,
but I really fucking enjoyed it.
And, uh, just even doing that,
I mean that how long it
takes to fly the pattern.
MMM.
I mean that couldn't have been more than
like felt like 90 seconds who probably,
maybe it was a little bit
longer. I don't know. But, uh,
yeah,
I dunno. It's just fucking definitely
left the place yesterday. You know,
that's one of those things where you'd
get did something great and you're
driving away and he got the window
down just driving right. Gone.
So anyways, you guys been
watching the playoffs? Yeah,
I'd say for first round playoffs.
I'll tell you the series I'm
watching obviously, and I'll say,
I'll tell you again, I'm just going
to keep saying, I'll tell you,
I'll tell you I'm watching
those Celtics and the bowls, um,
Celtics are now up three games
to two after being down. Oh, too.
After looking like we had
no fucking answers. Right.
And,
uh,
which is why my nod for MVP of the
series is Rondo without a doubt.
Because the second he went down the
series just completely changed. Yeah.
MMM.
And I thought all of the Bulls had,
is figured out,
but evidently it was rando he
knew what the fuck was going on.
I'm giving them full fucking
credit because it's just,
it's been a tale of two cities.
You know,
they looked like they were going to sweep
us and now it looks like we're going
to run the table on them. However,
however, I think Rondo is coming back.
He took his cast off,
his suits,
have long sleeves again and um,
I can't wait to watch games.
Six I want to see like,
is this guy is good is it appears in this,
in this series at last night,
admittedly the officiating was a little
subpar and it definitely went in the
Celtics favor and I loved with Lopez
was applauding the fucking refs.
Sometimes it's worth getting a fucking
technical. I love that guy, man.
That guy comes out every night, wants
to play. He's a little fucking weird.
He's on his own vibe. He just,
I, I really liked that guy.
I love when he fucking started clapping.
It's like my favorite thing.
And then they go to,
I think it actually works
because then we went down,
they called the ticky tack fall on the
other end and you saw Dwayne Wade was
whatever the Celtic said to him. I
think it might've been, uh, Isaiah,
he just started smiling and
laughing. I swear to God, man,
I just think the NBA is
so fucking controlled.
Okay.
I really do. Just for the
simple fact that you can do it.
I've said this a zillion times,
there is no easier game to
control or fix than basketball
cause it's the only fucking game
where you can sit down as a ref.
You can take people out of
the game, you know? I mean,
I guess all the games you can object
somebody, but they, you know in baseball,
football, hockey, you
really have to do something.
You just can't point at a guy and be like,
hey go sit on the fucking bench.
Well I guess you can in hockey.
Right.
I Dunno.
You know what?
That's one of those things where you
think you have a good theory and then you
fucking explore all the options. You like,
oh well maybe it doesn't work. Whatever.
Nope.
You only sit them down for like fucking
two minutes and they come back out and
it's not like,
well fucking Wayne Gretzky's got three
penalties to more and he's out of the
game right there. You got back on
track with my theory. There you go.
You can't sit Tom Brady down.
All you gotta like this is
what kills me about basketball.
I don't give a fuck how many points
you're up. You're up like 20 points.
You just like, yeah, this game's a
rep is one quarter ago. You don't,
most teams are lucky if they
score like 27 and a quarter,
that's like a fucking great quarter.
We're up by 20 all we really need to do
is score eight points and we're fine and
the next thing you know it's just like a
little fucking jerk offs are on a 27 to
run every fucking time.
That whole thing. It's a game
of runs. I don't think it is.
I think it's a game of fucking ratings in.
If a team gets up too high,
they just start fucking call Colin
files together to Ah, that's stupid.
That's a stupid fucking theory. But
it does. It just appears that way.
Maybe it is the nature of the game
that nobody can just blow somebody out.
They always come back. Like, I
would say like 85% of the time.
Of course I didn't do any research,
but you seem to be 85% of
the time you fucking go.
You go up by 30 points in the first half,
you know,
somehow by the end of the game,
that one away. What else? Sex.
One of the most unbelievable
and probable come back
since last night's fucking slew of
NBA Games into the exact same thing.
Um, anyways, I don't want to talk about
it. All I'm saying is that I think a
Rondo really showed,
I mean just, I mean it's
fucking unbelievable. Like
how much the series changed.
One guy is gone and the
whole thing turns around. Um,
so I'm excited to watch games six,
even if they win,
that'd mean I'd like seeing greatness.
I don't give a shit. I mean, I hope it's
on my team, but if it isn't the, I can't,
and then like I can't just sit
back and appreciate it. Right.
I try to be a good guy for right now.
I don't know why I have this fucking,
this pillow that wraps around you,
this little half circle pillow.
You know when you have a baby abuse,
it's perfectly set them down.
You give them the bottle of Jack, you
know, and then that's it. You know,
but if you try to do it with
regular pills, it doesn't work.
But for some reason I have it
around me right now. I don't know.
It feels right.
Like I don't wait to have a kid that buy
one of these fucking semicircle pillows.
Um, all right, what else did I
want to talk about? I've been watching,
you know, I've been watching the hockey.
Okay.
Gotten over the fact that my Bruins had
been knocked out by the quietest fan
based team in the league.
Right.
The team that cheering forgot until April.
Then all of a sudden they all show
up like they give a shit. Oh man,
that was fucking hard watching
that. Anyways, um, the
prejudice are looking great,
but I still think, I don't know
if I already talked about this.
I started this podcast twice. I forget
if I brought this shit up. I still,
I'm still going with the penguins. I
think the penguins repeat. Um, and I miss,
uh, Anaheim. Edmonton. I bet
that's a great fucking series too.
It's so crazy. They're already down
to just two series in each conference.
So I have to make sure that I'm watching,
um,
for those people last week you're like,
hey,
how come you didn't talk about Moto
GP, the race in Austin? You know what?
I didn't see it. And uh, then I,
I realized I recorded it
and this is what you learn.
If you're new to moto GP and you go to
record the race and you've got to fucking
do it.
It might,
it might be better than Formula One
just because of the sheer amount of like
passing in lead changes in all that.
It's fucking insane.
And then the fact he just watched
these guys falling off motorcycles.
I wrote one of the races. Um,
well let me explain it first.
You're going to go to record it.
If you're novice like me,
you go to record it and you'll be watching
like the first race and it will say
Moto too when they're on these little
skinny bicycle tires and you're like,
those don't look like the fucking,
you know,
those Badass bikes that I saw.
What's going on here?
Then there's moto three and you're like,
what is the real one? Was that Ross,
Valentino, Rossi guy? Whatever
the fuck his name is. Uh,
Mike and the mechanics,
whatever the other guy's name is.
I don't know any of the fucking name shed.
So there's three different classes.
This is what I learnt.
All right.
On Moto GP as they say.
And um,
there's Modo too.
There's moto three and there's moto GP
and that's basically like being in Aa Aaa
and then being in the majors.
Now for whatever reason,
Moto three is the lowest level. So
I guess they go in three, two, one.
I guess that's how they do it. And
they don't say one, they just say GP,
which I believe stands for Grand Prix.
I don't fucking know.
So motor three is 250
cc according to this,
this thing on reddit air to 250 cc bike,
you know,
so that's basically a cubic centimeters.
So it's a smaller engine.
It's not as fast, you know, it's still
fast as shit the way they're doing it.
But you know, that's the one like, okay,
all right, the grasshopper, we'll, we'll,
you know, we'll see how you do it
this level. And then if you, uh,
succeed at that level, then they move
you up to moto two, which is 600 CC's.
Evidentaly four strokes and all
the engines are made by Honda,
which I find interesting. Um, so hot,
they're all Honda base.
Everybody's working the exact same shit.
That's probably so they can
truly get an idea of who,
um, who is the best writer, who's going
to get called up to the show, Moto GP.
And according to this person,
a lot of times in Modo,
Modo to the race is better because they
all just have basically the exact same
engine.
So this guy was saying you could throw,
you can usually can throw a blanket over
the top three people in that race. Um,
and then the big show is moto
GP, which is a thousand CC's. Um,
and those things are just fucking rockets.
And I watched this whole thing on how
they build them. They're hand built,
gets how much those motorcycles
cost a piece. Take a wild guess.
Like if for some reason you
went down, they said, hey,
you want to take it for a lap?
But if you fucking trashed this thing,
you got to pay for it. Okay. And they give
you that fucking suit with the airbag.
And unfortunately you don't,
high site,
you slide off the bike and you get up
and be like, uh, shit, what's that?
Gonna cost me? I would've thought
anywhere between 102 hundred 50 grand,
you know,
and I
stand that it's a fucking racing
bike and all that, but you know,
they're a little less things.
Do you know what I mean?
You go to to do a build on a car,
this is like fucking people working on it.
On the other side. He can't even
see him a motorcycle. I mean it's,
it's right there.
Everything is right fucking there.
You want another guy can lift up
the engine and the shit is small.
If that was like a hundred,
a hundred to 250 grand is when I
would've guessed three 75 tops.
Right. This is like, I'm at the
showcase showdown on the prices, right.
And I horrifically
underbid is what happens.
Um,
those bikes cost $2 million each,
$2 million each. They're handmade. Um,
all this space age stuff. I watched
this whole thing on how they build them.
The gas tank is actually
underneath the seat.
What's where the gas tank usually is,
is the fuel injector.
There's an airport right in front of that,
right with the fucking front light.
Usually.
I just want to,
I watched the whole goddamn thing
was absolutely fascinating and a,
I'm totally in on that sport watching
that sport and I'm watching the F one.
I don't know when the next races, but,
uh, if you want to watch, do well,
I think it was a motto to race.
The last one,
this fucking guy came out of a turn
is backend started. Fishtailing yeah.
Like right up and over the handlebars
doing, I don't know how fast, I don't,
I don't get how they get up
because he,
he landed on like his foot.
He limped for a second and then he just
kinda just shakes it off. They're like,
hey, you said foot problems
said foot problems in the past.
I'd imagine you that everything
problems you fall off a bike.
You know, it's funny when I was thinking
about getting a motorcycle out here,
the stupidest thing you
could ever do. Um, you know,
riding a fucking motorcycle.
I know a lot of guys who will,
you just fucking flew a helicopter.
It's with way safer, way safer.
There's nobody up there. I was
actually driving back. I was did, um,
Mark Marin's podcast promoting
season two of F is for family.
I don't know when that's coming out.
MMM.
And thank you to mark Marin. Forget
me on his podcast. I had a great time.
We talked about anger, meditation, we
talked music and we help promote any,
help me promote the show.
And um, I was on my way back.
It was the middle of the day and all
of a sudden there was just all this
horrific traffic. And uh,
this big fucking accent is,
this truck had jumped at medium strip.
I don't have to guide median strip.
I don't if the guy fucking
fell asleep or whatever,
but 10 people went to the hospital,
one person died in a dog died,
you know, so I don't know.
I just think the highway is
way, way, way more dangerous.
I've said it before,
you're flying in formation,
the secure in the fucking blue angels,
everybody's still 80 miles an hour.
There's no radio contact. Nobody
knows where anybody is fucking going.
These people texting these people on meds,
you have no idea and they forget a bit.
And then right on the other side
is another group of fucking people.
You know,
there's never ending parade of fucking
people flying on the other side.
You don't know what they're going to do.
That fucking guy was driving a truck,
fell asleep, had a heart attack, whatever
the fuck he did jump the meetings,
strip went right up and over into
oncoming fucking traffic at like,
it was like 12 in the afternoon.
Did you look it up?
It's on was on the five right?
In your Colorado Boulevard.
MMM.
So anyways, so I was thinking about
getting a motorcycle when I was,
I was looking up those moto GP suits.
Yeah.
What's your like 2,500 bucks a whack,
but they got a little air bag in them.
And I'm like, well that's what
the fuck I would want. Yeah.
It'd be hilarious to buy one of those.
And then by like a fucking Harley
Davidson and just look like the biggest
fucking asshole ever. You just ride that
thing. If somebody cuts in front of you,
you just let it. But there's another thing
too, he's on those when they're racing,
you can lay it down and slide and fucking
all that stuff and you find, you find,
it's not like you can slide into oncoming
traffic and there's a good God damn
garbage truck coming at Ya.
MMM.
I Dunno, but I miss ride
motorcycle, so I'm taking a, ah,
it's just nothing safe about
them. I was thinking, all right,
well I'll just get a dirt bike.
I won't go over jumps or anything.
I'll just ride some trails. But then
every of ever like fucking, I don't know,
it seems like every six weeks you hear
a story about somebody riding on a trail
choosing a mountain bike though.
But if you run like a dirt bike at some
mountain line ends up like pouncing on
your back, which got the
helmet on. I Dunno. I Dunno.
I, I, you know what,
this podcast is going great and he
just went off the rails somewhere.
I don't really know where. Let's,
let's do a little bit of, uh,
advertising Indochino in Chino.
Yeah,
the sting wreath,
the Gordon Sumner read it.
Don't shy to talk about how
every man looks better in a suit.
You know, when I'm checking out guys
at the, at the outdoor mall, I'm like,
you know, I'm really attracted to that
guy, but he's just wearing an Izod,
you know, with some quarter
Roy's, that's not my all.
Now look at that fellow wearing this suit.
Now there's something I could take home
to my parents that said, everybody,
if you're sick of gay men not giving you
the fucking once over or maybe rolling
their eyes, you ever think that maybe
it's not you fucking love handles.
Maybe it's the fact that
you don't have on a shirt,
a tie and a sport coat to cover up
all the mistakes you've made with your
nutrition over the last 40 years.
Thank God there's Indochino is making
it easy to get a perfectly tailored suit
and an incredible price.
You can choose from hundreds of top
quality fabrics and personalize your suit
just the way you want it,
whether it's for work or a wedding
or another special occasion.
Here is how it fucking works.
Visit a showroom or shop online,
[inaudible] dot com pick your fabric.
Choose your customizations from lapels
to pleats to jacket linings in more.
Submit your measurements,
place your order and wait for it
to arrive and just a few weeks.
Then they'll sell all this,
your measurements and all that.
She'll sell all of that shit to
these fucking nerds making robots.
And next thing you know,
there's going to be a knock at the door
and all of a sudden you're going to be
looking right at yourself.
The robot version,
you wearing this suit you wanted and
that thing's going to get is you're going
to give up your back.
It's gonna fucking choke you out
in no matter how much you tap out,
those robots don't care.
But this week my listeners can get
any premium Indochino suit for $389.
That's right@indochino.com
when entering burr at checkout,
that's 50% off the regular price for
made to fucking measure premium suit.
Three to 89 bucks is not a
premium suits a nice suit. Uh,
the Indochina Doc,
that's indochino.com promo code bur
for any premium suit for $389 and free
shipping,
incredible deal for a suit that will fit
you better than anything off the rack
ever could yet 389 bucks actually for
a fucking fitted suit is going to be
great. You can walk into an
Applebee's and every chicken,
there's going to think you're a banker.
You've got to do it. Next thing you know,
right? You fucking, you know,
you ran away and trying to block up the
smell of that bloomin' onion that she's
been carrying around all day.
All right,
lift everybody you know about Lyft Rye.
It's the APP that gets you a ride in
minutes on demand 24 seven for less than
the cost of a cab.
Every Lyft driver is fully vetted
through their 10 point safety standard,
including criminal and
DMV background checks.
Unlike those other people with that
other thing that rhymes with mover,
right? You don't know what
you're going to get, right?
You can walk in there with a bloody ax.
Those fucking cops would hire, you know,
you'll get around quickly and safety with,
with Lyft,
Lyft drivers are rated after every ride,
so only the best stick around.
You don't have to worry about getting
into a filthy car with some creepy dude.
Everybody doesn't get a ribbon at Lyft.
The way they do over it. Mover with Lyft,
you can tip in the APP,
which obviously leads to happier drivers.
I mean I not attend Lyft riders get
a perfect five star rating from the
passenger. It's just a better way.
All better. All around experience.
Bigger isn't always better.
Lift isn't the biggest ride sharing app,
but it is the fastest
growing and I is created one.
I'm talking quality over quantity.
Thanks to lift you can get.
It's an easy way to avoid drunk driving.
You never have to bum a ride. Well,
what if you're on heroin? It's another
way to to avoid nodding off in public.
And then I noticed that guy, oh,
you're in the cab. Nobody knows.
And you know what a lot of people are
actually getting rid of their cars and
relying on Lyft to get around and
evidentaly. I don't blame them.
What do you do when the apocalypse,
when the zombies come,
you think you can fucking call Lyft that
Lyft drivers getting the fuck out of
there right now, Lyft is offering
our listeners a special deal.
Get three rides up to $10 each.
That's a $30 value in case you can't
do basic math when you enter Promo code
bill burr,
just download the free Lyft app today
and enter the Promo Code bilberry.
In the payment section. You'll start
with three free rides, up to $10 each.
That's up to a $30 value.
That's Promo Code Bill Burr,
B. I. L. L. E. B. U. R. R, no
space, all caps. All right.
How many more of these fucking things?
Oh Jesus. Oh, but these are quick.
He's a quick, let me tell you some of
dollar shave club upside and simply safe.
They respect the fact that I'm
not good at reading out loud.
So these are three quick paragraphs.
Here we go.
Run in the table just like the Celtics
on the bulls. Second Rondo sat down, Bam,
Bam, Bam. Three to two Celtic. Sorry.
Doll is shave club is the smarter choice.
You'll get a great shave at a great price.
Conveniently delivered right to your door.
You do.
You no longer have to Schlep to the store
to buy a cheap disposable radios razor
that gives you a cheap shave or spend a
fortune on raises with gimmicky shaving
tech you don't need and when you use
dollar shave club's the executive razor
with the executive razor comes with the
date rape drug in the fucking handle.
Some creepy banker walking around in his
gold toed socks shape and is nuts. No,
that's not what you do. That's
a different read. Sorry.
The Dollar Shave Club's executive
razor with their Dr Covey's easy shape.
The blade just gently glides
giving you a smooth shave.
Dr Carver's shave butter is
transparent for a more precise shave,
helps prevent ingrown hairs and fights.
Razor bumps make the smarter choice by
joining Dollar Shave Club for a limited
time.
New members can get their first month
of the executive razor with a tube of
their doctor cavities
falling $5 with free shipping and after
that the raises are just a few bucks a
month. There's no hidden fees and no
commitments. Cancel any time you want.
Join the club today@dollarshaveclub.com
slash burr that's dollar shave club.com/
[inaudible] all right. Upside just
sounds like a date movie, right?
He went to go see upside.
The downside of the upside.
Do you want to go see that
stars Tom Hanks. Meg Ryan,
Hugh fucking let me get a hooker
or whatever the fuck his name was.
Who was an English guy
used to go out with Elizabeth Berkley.
San Hugh Jackman.
He's the guy who a seed,
a whole chicken every
day to become wolverine.
I don't remember Hugh
Grant to grant you ready?
You Bet. You Bet. He get
in the fucking hooker. Hey,
I never judged that guy. You got
to hook her. Why? Why wouldn't you?
Why wouldn't you? What else are you going
to do? What else are you going to do?
What? Go home and make some fucking
Chiffey pop fucking Hugh grant.
You're crushing it. You're a fucking
movie star in your own country.
You go across the pond, you
know? Oh, who's kidding?
Who England is like Moto Moto
three fucking America is moto GP.
That's what you want to have.
You hit movies. You guys
all know it's true. Christ,
you're all still in our blue jeans.
You all, you are, you're, you hate us,
but you love our culture.
Isn't it safe to say that?
Not fucking with the actually motions of
looking jeans can completely, all right.
Upside. There's a better way
for you to buy business travel.
It's called upside.com.
Every time you buy a trip it upside.
You'll save your company a ton of money
and they give you an Amazon card with
hundreds of dollars upsides able to do
this because they bundle your flights and
hotels together for one low price.
That's what they do.
They rip this seats out of a commercial
airliner and they just stuff you in
there. You know, you might think flying,
standing up like you're at a mosh pit
for six hours from New York to La. Mike,
suck. Yeah, talks to me when
you that only cost you 40 bucks.
Now that's not what they do. Um, bundle
pricing saves money. This is what they do.
If you're a frequent business traveler,
you're company saves a ton of money and
you can get thousands a year and gift
cards just for buying your air
and hotel together at upside.
You just fucking said this,
plus you still get your miles
to what the f I feel like in the end
of this you can be missing a kidney.
This seems like too,
too good a deal.
And I get a gift card and I get to keep
my miles and I saved them a bunch of
money. If you're shopping for business
travel and you'd be crazy not to check out
upside.com you're out of your mind.
It just takes three minutes to see how
much you can say by buying your flights
and hotels together for
one low price. Oh, I see.
They both cut side deals with each other.
Somebody's gotta be doing, you know,
at some point somebody got sold
into fucking sex slavery here.
This is just too good a deal.
And right now the human trait,
right?
And right now when you use my name Bar,
you're guaranteed to get at least a
100 Amazon gift cards. Your first trip.
That's my name. [inaudible] to get
at least $100 Amazon gift card free.
Save big on travel and get
a big gift card every trip.
I love upside.com evidently
upside.com minimum purchase required.
See Site for complete details are
right. Here's the last one, everybody.
It's simply safe.
Yeah.
If you're not there when a fire starts,
simply safe can be
there to save your home.
I want those instead of fucking throw you
into it. I wasn't there, but we'll put,
we'll put you right back in it.
It's kind of a good thing if you're
not there when the fire starts, right?
Okay.
Simply safe can be there to
save your home. All right.
This is a robot that
has a fire extinguisher.
What is this with simply
safe home security,
you'll get a 24 seven
connection to dispatch and
Lightening Fast Response Times
in emergencies. All right,
I have to look up dispatch.
What does dispatch?
All I know is I have 24 fucking
okay.
24 hour access to dispatch,
dispatch.com that's not what I wanted.
That's not what I wanted.
Why don't you wish there was like
voice command on these things?
Okay.
Then you compute will be like, what
did you want? What did you want?
Okay.
Oh, for fuck sakes, it'll load eventually.
I'll tell you what that means later.
Dispatch. Oh, here it is. It is a
sendoff. Oh, fucking Christ.
Don't just happened to come on.
Now want us to load again?
Send off to destination or for a purpose.
Deal with the task,
the sending of someone or something
to a destination for a purpose.
So they're going to send somebody who
has a purpose in life to your house.
When it's on fire,
they're going to walk up the street
holding their fucking head. Hi.
I'm imagining that person would, you know,
be driving a fire truck. Fire engine,
right? All right. The system is
easy to use and completely wireless.
You can install it
yourself in under an hour.
No installation guy drilling holes
in your walls. No ugly wires.
Simply safe's founder and chief engineer
thought of everything when he built
this system. Backup batteries for
your base section station. Sorry.
A cellular connection to the authorities.
There are no long term contracts,
no commitment to no hidden fee.
Simply safe's round the clock.
Professional security monitoring is just
1499 a month order today and you'll get
a special 10% discount.
Go to simply safe bird.com that's s I m
P L I s a f e burg.com for 10% off your
home security system. Simply safe.com
simply safe burrow.com sorry.
Alright. Is that it? Is that, and I
think I talked about everything right?
Yeah. I believe I hit everything
that I want to talk about. You know,
I was just checking in on you.
Here's some fucking music. Uh,
excuse me that you guys
can listen to a man.
We got another like half hour of stuff
from classic podcasts from a or a Monday
and a year, a day a week gone by.
That's it. Go fuck yourselves.
I believe there's another f one race this
Sunday. Check it out. If you can, uh,
let's go sell dicks. I'm hoping
for a classic. I hope he went,
but I also want to see Rhonda would
come out and do his thing too.
You know what I mean? Cause I still love
that guy. He's still a Celtic to me.
All right.
That's it.
Have a great weekend you cunts
and I'll talk to you on Monday.
Hey,
what the fuck I'm talking about?
We decided to have a fucking
party for our new place. You know,
you think that was my idea.
Do you think it was my idea to have a
bunch of strangers come into the fucking
house? I'll have people
over. That's what I do. Hey,
you want to come over and watch the
game? Nine people that I know, right?
Have all your fucking phone numbers.
You don't. Nia is a more open person.
So she's like, let's have a
party. All right, so we sit,
she goes to invite your friends. So I'm
all right. So you know, I got, you know,
I'm a, I'm a guy, I don't
have a bunch of friends. Okay.
I got six good friends for that.
I could really trust, you know,
it's about it,
at least out here.
Then over here in neah talking to her
mom about all excited about the party and
she's like, yeah, I thin it out a foot
Facebook. And I was just like, oh my God,
did I just invite 110 people
in my heart literally sank on.
Please tell me you didn't just invite
110 fucking people. She's like,
don't worry, they're not all
gonna show up. It's like,
yeah, but like a third will.
And then they're going to bring people
that you don't even fucking know.
And that's exactly what happened.
It was a fucking great party.
I'm not gonna lie to you, but I got
to admit, like I got to learn how to,
I thought I was going to be a
good host. I wasn't. I wasn't.
I was all right with the people I
knew. But the people I didn't know, uh,
they actually, most of them are all
right, but there were a couple of them.
I just find it just sends you something
fucking annoying about somebody you
don't know, sitting on your
goddamn couch, you know,
eating your food, drinking your booze.
He like, who the food of fuck are you?
And somebody else was laying down on
the floor. I felt like the kids' Dad,
I want to make, get them
get a fucking job. Right?
It's over you 26 she fucking pump.
So anyway, so the party going great.
And uh, I'm basically the whole time,
you know, not drinking too much,
but I'm standing by the front tour cause
that's the only way out. All right.
And nobody's walking out
with any of my shit, right?
I'm acting basically like psycho in
fucking stripes. That's how I am.
It's how I'm wired.
All right?
So a fucking three quarters away through
the party, everything's going great.
And I'm like, wow, this is, you know,
I forgot, I forgot. I'm not 21 anymore.
I'm fucking 43.
All my friends are adults and everybody's
drinking responsibly and no one's
really hammered. Nothing got
broken. Everything's cool.
So start just as I was starting to
relax some kid up to me. He's like
a, yeah, yeah, you own the house.
And I'm like, well, the bank owns it.
I'm fucking paying it off.
What can I do for you?
And he's like a yes,
kind of embarrassment,
but I use the bathroom downstairs and uh,
it's clock now.
And I was wondering if you had a plunger.
And I was like,
yeah, I do have a plunger. I got a
plunger right here, the upstairs bathroom.
So I give it to the guy and I, and I say,
man, I appreciate your honesty. He goes,
no problem. He goes downstairs, he takes
care of it, comes back, he wants again.
He goes, he goes, sorry about that.
I said, not at all, not at all.
What the fuck is the toilet, you
know, plugs up every once in a while.
But I appreciate you. I
appreciate your honesty. You know,
cause I would have been nasty.
Good for you. Right. So, uh,
now the couple of hours goes by,
the party ends and there's
like one straggler left. And
I tell the story to knee.
I'm like, you know what a
good, what a good guy. What
a good shit. No Pun intended.
You know we could have left it in there.
Now that you got a party,
I come walking in my fucking bathroom,
looks like a Goddamn port authority
bus station, toilet. You know,
cause I was psyched. So, so one of the
stragglers at the party, he goes yeah,
he goes, I saw that whole thing go down.
That's not exactly how it went down.
I'm like, what are you talking
about? He goes, he goes,
it wasn't him that was in the
bathroom. And I go, who was, he goes,
it was his girlfriend.
Some lady took a dump of a magnitude
that it wouldn't go down the toilet.
So now she's in there panicking and this
is when today's technology kicks in.
She can add it back in the day.
She would have had to crawl out the
fucking window and hope nobody saw her and
just left the door locked. Everybody
would have panicked. Holy Fuck.
Who's in there? Did somebody pass out? If
somebody, if somebody committed suicide,
some of what? It kicked
in the door. Alright.
Knocked it off the fucking goddamn
hinges and you go in there,
there'd be nobody in there.
You'd feel the air from outside and
then look down and everyone would see a
giant shit and be like,
whoa.
As a party would be over and the owner
of the house would be walking around
going home.
Why are you mother fucking Jared
told you mother Fucker,
you better drive away. Right.
That's how I would have ended.
But because of today's technology,
not saying she didn't panic,
you know,
it's even worse is a lady,
cause they're not even supposed to
do stuff like that. Right. And uh,
she was able to text her boyfriend and I
would fucking pay at least $400 to read
those texts,
the panic in those texts.
And to his credit,
he fucking EHC stepped it up.
He took the hit,
he came up to me,
v h one ones I love the
eighties on Belper and said,
I took a dump in your toilet.
Do a magnitude that didn't
go down and need the tools
required to alleviate this situation.
So Anti Douche bag of the week,
that guy right there.
So taking a fucking
bullet for the team that,
that right there is the
reverse Peyton manning award.
He didn't fucking go, we had protection
issues, right? No, he took one.
He took one for the fucking tape,
went upstairs like a God.
They have gentlemen asked for a plunger,
gave it to him and it was all fun and I
went down there at the end of the party.
You never would've known anything,
anything happened. You know what I mean?
Like, uh, you know, three hours after
the Kennedy assassination. I bet it was.
It was all I would say it,
you know,
marked it all up and everything was all
figured out, but it was a nice road.
Again,
mopped up the brain talking to her and
it is Monday morning podcast from Monday,
April 20 something 2009.
I don't know what the fuck it is.
You know, I really don't.
I really don't. All right.
I feel like shit.
Uh,
I had a really rough weekend in Columbus,
Ohio,
but before I get into the details,
I want to thank everyone who came out
on a Friday, Saturday, and Sunday.
I had a great time.
I had too good of a time.
Let's put it that way. Um, yeah.
Too good a time to go to fucking time.
And I'm paying for it right now.
You know? I don't know why I keep
doing this. I don't know why.
I just can't learn, you know?
You know I always do overrated,
underrated on this shit.
All you know what's fucking underrated?
Eight hours sleep, you
know? You know what's,
you know what's fucking underrated going,
hey, you want another shot at Jamieson?
You know what? No, I think I've had
enough. You know what I would like?
I would like a water that's underrated.
You know,
not going to fucking steak and shake at
three in the morning. That's underrated.
Yeah, one of those fucking double burgers.
I never even made it that place before.
It didn't even look like meat like a patty
in order I've had. He looks like, sure.
We all do. We've all had a fucking burger.
Even you little Veggie cons out there,
you know what it looks like.
This is a little burned up
wig and there was two of them.
You know what?
I was kind of a 40 year old fucking guy
going to be 41 in fucking June goes to
steak and shake at three in the fucking
morning when he's got a Goddamn fucking
eight 40 in the morning flight.
Why would you do that?
Schererville you suck at math. We
all know that, but she can tell time.
I know there's numbers
involved of Jesus Christ.
What a fucking idiot.
This whole fucking,
I just thinking about that boogie nights.
I'm a fucking idiot fucking idiot Eddie,
and I'm a fucking Eddie.
I'm a fucking idiot.
Twice Friday night,
ended up at steak and shake at
three in the morning. You know,
fucking Sunday night I was
as far as I didn't walk in.
They weren't like no norm like on
chairs areas again, all shit faced.
Jesus Christ.
What a fucking motley crew.
You want to see a motley crew go to a
fucking steak and shake at three in the
fucking morning.
Good God Almighty.
Now I'll tell you, I was part
of the problem. I was, you
know, I bet I was doing it.
Everybody else was doing.
They were all sitting in their shit face
looking around. Everybody else gone.
Jesus Christ, look at, okay,
that fucking guy. Oh my God.
Look at her. She's wearing
slippers. Jesus Christ.
You know you don't even realize
they're doing it to you too.
I'm going to have fucking guy. Huh?
Look at that. Look at his fucking eyes.
What does, it's almost like he's
been drinking Jameson all night. Why?
When did you get a water after
awhile? What a fucking idiot. Yeah.
Let me have one year burnt
up wig fucking burgers. Ah,
why is shit food so good when
you, when you shit faced? Yeah.
Is that what it is? Shit. Face Shit.
Food is just, it's just all shit shit.
Fucking decisions. I didn't want
to do that man. I was doing well.
You know I went to trader Joe's,
you know,
dodged a bunch of fucking Bergen
stock. Hippies and I, you know,
I went in there and I, I, Oh I,
I got the fridge put in my room.
Fuck global warming. I want to be in
shape. I had a fridge, put my Romeo.
I had got all this healthy food.
What do I do?
I go out,
I go drinking to water four
nights like a fucking more,
oh my God, I went to this
one. You know what I had,
I had a slice of pizza last night
too. That's so fucked up. I was,
this is like all coming. It's
like a slide show. You know,
you can't remember this shit that
happened in between, but you just,
you just have pictures.
Yeah.
Good.
God Almighty was at a bad looking pizza.
Is there anything fucking worse than
that? Just a bad look. And it just,
you know those, you know when
someone makes a pizza, right?
And it even sucks when it's hot,
but then it just sits there for
awhile and it just gets that,
that a cold case file look to it.
You know what I mean?
Like it should have a fucking toe
tag hanging off the crust. They,
they brought over a whole pie
that look like that. You know,
they looked like some five year old made
it and like an easy bake oven, you know,
and you're their parents. And now you
have to eat it and say, oh, Susie,
it's delicious. You know, just begin.
Begin her little life of people lying to
her and not being fucking honest saying,
no, don't wear that. You look
fat in that. No, you just go,
oh, Susie York. Beautiful.
That's an excellent pizza you made.
You know what, Susie? It fucking sucks.
All right. I'm not saying to give
up your dream about being a cook,
but you definitely don't fucking have
any talent at this point in your life.
You know, maybe we can send you to
some sort of, uh, oh, Jesus Christ.
What are those chefs schools called?
Huh? Well, what does that art called?
You know, come on. You know what it is
because of the sea. It's not custodial.
It's not calm. Macerich he plays for
fucking the Canadians. Oh, Canadians.
I want to say a bone, Julia to all my
friends up there in Montreal. You know,
I was just breaking your balls. I've
been blogging for the Bruins and, uh,
is basically I went down as blogging
for the Bruins during the playoffs,
which I'm going to continue to do because
they swept the Montreal Canadians. Um,
and basically, uh, you know,
I have to blog for the Bruins that
playing and Canadians. I mean, what do,
what do you, what am I going to
say? The Canadians won 24 cups.
We've only want five.
We haven't won since 1972.
All I can do is just try to piss you
off. That's all I was doing. I said,
Montreal fans get really, really fucking
mad. You know, I made fun of their coach.
I just did what I get. Oh, I
just made fun how they looked,
how they blew their fucking players.
I don't even more,
I said I was just trying to be a jerk
and as people got all [inaudible] noise,
you were hockey.
You know,
this guy calls himself a comedian.
I don't take,
this is very funny.
Whatever,
you know,
it's fucking funny.
I heard Celine Dion is thinking
about buying the Montreal Canadiens.
He's probably gonna move him to Vegas.
That'd be a fucking mascot on ice.
That would be, that would be a crime.
That'd be a goddamn crime. All right.
This is the Monday morning podcast.
This is the hangover episode
of the Monday morning podcast.
I am sitting in a hotel in Manhattan,
New York. Why are you doing that, bill?
Huh?
You lay in low after a weekend of Busan.
Now I've got a week at Caroline's and
I'm working with Joe de Rosa once again,
my partner in crime too.
Codependent fucking alcoholics.
Do you know one time,
I think I might have told this story on
ONA opie and Anthony Show for you? Uh,
people who live in, I don't
know, fucking North Dakota. Um,
I don't know when that,
it wasn't Caroline's Caroline's comedy
club on Broadway where I will be Thursday,
Friday, Saturday and Sunday
for a fucking 22 shows,
22 fucking shows. I can't even do one
show at this point. I'm laying low, man.
I'm laying low. Um, but
anyways, one night I was,
I was standing there at
the bar and I decided,
I didn't know if I decided I wasn't going
to drink, but I just wasn't drinking,
you know, and all of a sudden who comes
walking down the stairs, you know,
like some starlet in the 1950s making a
big fucking debut Joe to Rosarito do you
think was missing was the
fucking the evening gown.
He comes fucking Walson down the
stairs, you know, all dainty, like,
and the second I saw him, I was like,
fuck, now I've got a drink. Right.
And you know what, he was thinking the
exact same thing. That was a funny thing.
Neither one of us wanted a drink. You
got any friends like that? You just,
you just been fuck ups for so long that
neither one of you can just pull you out
of the tailspin. I'm sure.
Anybody who's in in Aa good.
Tell me what exactly that that's called,
what kind of friendship that is?
Um, I don't fucking know.
I, I really, I really,
really feel like shit right now and a,
so I'm setting the room and uh,
if you noticed the quality
might be a little bit better.
Actually got a microphone now and I have
a little mixer and I have my headphones
on and I'm sitting here in the
fucking dark. That's not true.
I got the one little desk light on,
uh,
basically talking to myself. You know,
technically once you start listening,
this whole thing makes sense.
But Right now before I upload this thing,
this is really, uh, you know,
this is why they don't give
everybody handguns. Because
if one was laying around,
I'm fucking with you.
You know what I would do?
I'd probably pointed out the window.
I wouldn't shoot anybody.
Just try to scare someone,
maybe make me laugh and I could get a
little oxygen or something into my fucking
head. What do you guys, what do
you guys use for hangovers? Huh?
Other than the smart thing,
not drink anymore. God Damn.
It's just so much fun though. You
know, I was having a great time.
You know those broads, you know,
just having a good fucking time.
Just a good time. You know that
fucking people who like to drink.
I met a couple of hunters. I am at a
couple of dancers. I man, you know,
I met a, you know, a nice mix of
people as I'm a fucking weird dude man.
I don't like people before I get onstage,
I don't want to see him.
I don't see anybody in the fucking crowd.
But the second the show's over,
if somebody is cool, I, I,
that's the part of the show I I enjoy
and I become like this fucking ah,
Charlie rose and I just started
interviewing people. You know,
what's it like to shoot a pheasant in the
face? Huh? What's that like? You know,
do you got a little fucking couple of
pieces of wood that you rubbed together
and somehow it sounds like a pheasant
going, hey Eddie, come on over here.
You know, or whatever fucking pheasants
names are. If you had a pet pheasant,
what would you name it? Huh? Larry,
that'd be a great name for a pheasant.
Has to be funny. If you had it right and
people looking at it like, oh my God,
is that a pheasant? Like Larry,
get the fuck off of that thing.
Actually got off of it,
you know?
And then he got on a late night talk
show and then you went out there and then
it didn't work. And then the host
sorta mugged about how it didn't work.
And then maybe it takes a Turd on his
fucking wing tip shoe and 50 years later
it's part of the greatest hits DVD,
you know?
And little did you know that that was a
pinnacle of your life is a fucking zoo
keeper. That one moment you thought
it was going to keep happening?
No one episode one episode and you never
asked back because your animal shit on
the fucking host shoe wasn't
supposed to do that. It didn't do,
they didn't do it in the rehearsals.
All right,
how the fuck am I going
to maneuver this here?
All the rattling in the background.
I couldn't move my mixer or you know,
I feel right now I feel like the
fucking unit Obama all this, Goddamn,
was he anti-technology though?
I Dunno if he was anti or pro at all.
I know he was definitely fucking alone
and it was a paranoid son of a bitch.
My back. There we go. You guys
get nervous there for a second.
What the fuck does too
many fucking cords here.
I'm going to go back to this cell phone.
I'm not on holding my fucking laptop
like a goddamn. Yeah. You know,
servants used to hand shit to kings.
Would they put something on a pillow
and then they had the little hands
underneath it? That's the way I'm
holding it. I'll tell you what,
can I paint a fucking picture? Can
I paint a goddamn picture? Let me,
let me adjust the microphone. I want to
tell you about my microphone. By the way,
do you remember back in the
1970s, you know, nowadays,
whenever somebody has a mic,
uh, and they have like a little filter on
that, a filter or whatever, I don't know,
the technical,
you know,
little spongy thing that you stick on
there so it doesn't pop or if there's some
sort of wind, you know, nowadays that
just black and it just looks like a,
you know, fucking giant cock
just sitting there, right?
Something that they can put on TV, you
know. But back in the day, man, the 70s,
you know,
when people were buying weed by the
fucking garbage bag full and uh,
you know, the 70s were colorful man,
you fucking day just start it off.
You know,
you had that crazy cereal that they used
to have somebody brought a booberry or
count Chocula and Franken Berry and I
was in the cereal aisle. Uh, you know,
the other day, well, when
I went to trader Joe's,
when I was going to have a healthy week
before I down five bottles of whiskey on
the worst drunk too, I'm one of
those guys, I fucking call up people.
And start telling him I love him, you
know, and one of those guys, you know, I,
I do everything but ended up in the drunk
tank on the fucking Andy Griffith show.
I'm such an old school drunk,
but I'm not an angry guy when I get drunk.
I'm really not. I'm actually
pleasant and I'm able to emote.
Is that why you do it,
Bill? I don't fucking know.
All I know is it makes me feel like shit
the fuck was I just talking about? Oh,
how coat colorful the
seventies where yeah,
you'd start off with that fucking
cereal that they had and uh,
it was one of the worst sentences ever.
Yeah.
He started off with that cereal that
they had. Oh, there you go, Bill.
That's a great way to, to fucking
start it off. Right. If you,
Patty yourself on the back about how
you could paint a visual, you know,
it's funny,
I have headphones on right now.
I have no idea how a lot I'm talking and
I'm sure that there is somebody on the
other side of this wall that is
contemplating calling the front desk,
but what they're to is so fucking bizarre.
They haven't been able to tap out yet.
Um,
well that's arrogant bill.
Maybe they're listening and your sound
fucking annoying. All right. Whatever.
Stop Heckling yourself. Get to
the point. Yeah, you'd start off.
Will you eat tricks?
You booberry the shit literally
change the color of your milk,
which is some really hacky comedy from
fucking the 80s but I'm telling you,
you had that shit going on honeycomb,
you know the,
the fucking people were
wearing polyester at the,
I mean Shit was loud in the 70s
you know those plaids slacks,
people had slacks, he had boots had set
up the side. They're all fucking shiny.
Women had like those, those plastic
looking purses. It was fucking freaky.
It was weird.
Everything was like done.
Suddenly I think the
advertisers just like, look,
everybody's on drugs so we,
we really need to enhance their trip.
So much shit in the 70s was like really
done to like even like the fucking
monkeys,
which I guess you know was that this?
That was the late sixties I think I went
to the early seventies we were one when
they used to fucking,
you know,
pretend to sing in pathend
to play instruments at the
end of the show there and
they would,
they would cut to that little musical
montage is and they'd always do like half
the time they would do like those,
they'd put it in like a kaleidoscope.
So you had them actually in the middle
and then like six of them like going
around like a fucking that
fucking revolver aside,
I don't know what it was.
And you're eating that cereal.
He just watching this shit.
Anyways,
this all comes around to my microphone.
Back then you couldn't even watch like
a sport show without sort of tripping,
you know what I mean?
Like they had ABC's wide world of sport
and they had these fucking bright yellow
sport coats on and I used to have these
microphones and when they stood outside,
the little spongy thing that
they stuck on top wasn't black.
It didn't blend in with the microphone.
There were these crazy colors.
And one that I always remember was
there was always like bright orange.
It made no fucking sense.
But as a kid I liked it.
So whatever.
I bought a microphone and the guy goes,
what kind of wind screen do you want? You
know, you want the standard black one?
I said, fuck that. I want that one.
Keith Jackson used to use when he do
Monday night football way back in the day
or Redo the college games. Remember
Keith Jackson? Huh? Hello again.
Everybody that says kicked Jackson.
Remember that guy? Alabama,
Crimson tide and I'm fucking
world learnings. I Michigan,
they're going to be Schwab and paint. Um,
anyways. Yeah, so that's what I got here.
That was a really long fucking
way to go to explain that.
I put an orange spongy thing in the
end of my fucking Mike and I'm a Jew.
I know I'm cursing a lot right now and
I'm cursing. I'm not cursing at you guys.
Okay? Sometimes people get
confused. Stop cursing at me.
I'm not cursing at you and cursing and
my hangover because I described shit to
you. All right? Jesus Christ. Look at
this fucking fake wood in this desk.
This is the kind of desk that you sit,
you know that you sit at when
you're like confessing to a murder.
You know what I mean? And you just
sitting in there trying to wear you down.
They bring in some food acting
like they're your friends.
I was just watching those fucking
cold case files, man. God Damn,
those things are creepy.
He just fucking creepy.
Just watching the people when they come
in and, and they, and they, and they,
they get questioned for the murder and
they just sounded like, you know, regular,
regular guys. Where were you that
night? Ah, you know, I was home
watching a basketball game, you
know, just chilling out at a pizza.
Find out he fucking hacks up 23
people. Then when they, when they,
when they admit it, they're like, oh yeah,
yeah, yeah, I did it. You know, they,
they found this one guy that, that, uh,
who's that fucking guy that
the green river, I never,
they always got to give them nicknames,
the fucking news so they
can sell more papers.
They give them nicknames like they're
going to the rose bowl. Shit, you know,
crazy legs Johnson,
he's killed 48 fucking people.
They call me ice man.
Um, anyways, so there,
there's one guy up in Seattle,
right? He killed all these,
all these women who was brutal and uh,
they picked the guy up,
he never been arrested
before and they, they, they,
they meet them outside of his job
cause they put together a case. Okay.
He has no idea that they're
onto them. And they got, they,
the cops come up to the guy and they
say, listen buddy, uh, where, you know,
fucking whatever the police officer's,
I choose to try to get a headache.
I don't know what the fuck they say.
You know, they say hi, we're cops.
And we're here to arrest you for
the murder of four women. Now,
if you've never been arrested before, when
your heart drop, that guy just is like,
he, I guess evidently he just went, oh,
okay. Then they brought him down there,
he confessed to that and he confessed to
like fucking 60 other women that he had
killed. So they bring this guy into, uh,
another room to talk to what?
To a psychologist, you know,
cause he wants to try to break them down
so you can figure out so he can stop
these maniacs. Right. And they asked
the guy this question, they said, ah,
you know, if you could, um,
you could pick out one thing about your
personality that you feel is different
from the average person walking
down the street, what would that be?
And without missing a beat, the guy said,
ah, that whole, that whole caring thing.
Wow. You know, when you think you
don't give a fuck Jesus Christ,
just regular. Yeah. The whole Karen,
that whole caring thing. Yeah.
I just don't seem to give a
fuck. It's weird, you know,
I don't know. I hate watching that.
I don't know why I watch that show.
That show literally gives me nightmares.
You know what I mean?
You start thinking about what?
This is not funny.
What the fuck am I talking
about? See, this is what happens.
This is what happens when
you go out boozing. I,
you know what the sad thing is as I know,
at some point at some point this weekend,
I'm probably going to do this again.
But fortunately I'm in New York City
so I want end up at a steak and shake.
I have never eaten there. I think
I've made fun of that fucking place
on these podcasts. How would you rate,
how would you guys out there? Huh?
All my listeners out there, please tell
me you listen and please tell me I'm not.
I'm done.
Just sitting here baking under this
fucking hotel lamp for nothing.
How would you rate the worst?
Your worst?
Like a fast food, you know
what I mean? Everybody, you
know, no one wants to eat it,
but we all eat it cause you know it
tastes good. Fucking tastes good.
But then there's, there's
certain ones, either you had,
either you had a bad experience or
you, uh, just the look of it. You know,
I got, let's say for me like Taco
Bell, I just can't go in there.
There's just something about
the colors on the sign. They,
it just makes my stomach hurt.
You know,
you just get that awful feeling
in your stomach. You know,
I fell the same way about like Arby's.
He's never fucked with RBS.
Yeah.
Um, Mcdonald's guy. I'm old
school. I like Mcdonald's
in and out of this shit,
but you know,
I got a lot of memories
as a kid at Mcdonald's,
so I think that one's still wins even
though in and out is even better.
But there's just certain ones I won't
even go into, you know? All right guys.
I'm fucking fade and fast. Jesus Christ.
I need a fucking water or something.
The hell did I do with that water?
Didn't I have water around here?
Hang on a second. Yeah. Jesus Christ.
Fucking water I should had
last night. All right, let's,
let's get on with the questions
here. Um, if you're new to my page,
you probably think I'm out of my
fucking mind and you would be right.
I am out of my mind,
but you know what?
Yeah,
you know what? I don't have anything
to say to that. I am guilty as charged.
What are you fucking perfect.
Why don't you go to sit tough fucking www.
I'm fucking perfect.com and
go listen to that podcast.
I bet there's a lot of fucking lapse on
that one. You know? Did they got a mixer?
I've got gotta fucking mixer.
Bitch. You liked that shit.
Yeah,
I'm learning a lot of computer stuff.
You know what?
How about you guys make me computer
literate? Can you do that for me?
I'll start off with something really easy.
Something that really fucking annoys
me on my computer. And you know what?
Maybe someone else does this.
Maybe this annoys someone else who
has a computer who also has a drinking
problem. Okay. And then, uh, you
know, I'll read how to do it. I mean,
I can help another drunk out there.
All right.
This is one of my problems that I have
when I go to,
when I go into to apple works.
Right.
The text is so fucking small. I
don't understand it. It's set.
I know how to change it, but I gotta
change it every time. All right.
Right now it's stuck on 12 okay.
Which is basically squint size.
You know when I copy and paste your guys'
emails into my fucking thing, it's it.
It makes it smaller.
I don't know what it's doing.
I wanted at 18 I want the default set
at 18 how the fuck do I do that in apple
works? I've got a brand new MAC book.
I want to learn how to do that. Okay.
I want to learn some shit. You
know? I know how to upload.
I know how to do this now. Look at
me. I don't know what to upload. Shit.
I'll turn it into a fucking MP3.
I'll send it right to you.
I know how to do that now.
I feel great.
It's my new opening line when
I hit on chicks in the road.
You know what's up, sweetie? Are
you doing? You'd like to show.
Do you know I can also upload audio
files and turn them into an MP three Oh,
put it on a desktop. A fucking
drag it right over there. Same Way.
I'm going to drag you across the
fucking carpet and Mike Hotel.
What the fuck is that? All right. Can
somebody teach me how to do that, please?
Okay, and let's get on with the podcast
here. You know what the problem is? Is,
is not enough fucking room here. Well, I
got it. Why don't I just move this dude,
I even have a little stand here for my
microphone. I have a little fucking stand.
This is like a,
I dunno,
this is one of these like really nerdy
things that if you start when you're 18
by the time you're 30 you're famous
and you're not a nerd anymore.
Like chicks want to fuck you.
It's on, it's unreal. But
when you start this at 40,
it's just pathetic and
sad. Okay, here we go.
We're going to go to a, I already did
the underrated, so I don't, I do over it.
Um, I know this is really, this is
really coming off grumpy. I understand,
but whatever, you know,
last week I was pissed.
This week on grumpy. You know what? I'm
due for a happy one about next week.
Next week, be all bubbly and I won't be
cause I'll be flying across this country.
Oh man, that's gonna suck.
Let's not think about that dino.
Like I literally fall asleep on the plane.
I've flown across this country so many
fucking times that I can literally look
down and pretty much guess
what state I'm over. You know,
as a passenger I can do that. Why these
levels so low but the fuck is going on.
There we go. Might not talking into
this thing. Hello, test. There we go.
You know what I mean? I can
look out. I can tell, you know,
pretty good. I mean, Rick,
I dunno. Wait a minute.
What the fuck am I bragging about?
What does southwest is a desert.
Do you get into Colorado? You've got
the mountains, starts getting flat.
You're like, all right, this is the
Brassica Kansas. Maybe we're in the Iowa.
He starts seeing more lights.
You moving towards fucking
into Illinois. Right. And that
all works. I don't fucking know.
Like I actually like,
I recognize like lakes now,
you know, I can look down at my watch.
Ah, you know what? It's taken this long.
We're right about here and we should be
seeing Cleveland coming by. There it is.
There it is. I looked down sometimes
to look at fucking stadiums.
All my fucking life is now.
If I could be outside the plane and look
at my stupid round head looking out of
that little oval fucking window.
This is what I signed up for.
This is how fucking hung over I am.
I'm actually bitching that I'm a comedian.
Something that I wanted to do something
that I decided to do. All right.
Jesus Christ. There was a way for you
guys to email me a fucking tampon.
I think I get like 9 million this
week. All right. Uh, here we go.
Let's read the overrated. All
right, let's get into your thoughts.
I think you've heard enough from me for
one week. All right. Over eight bill.
All right, Bill. Uh, I
think this is overrated.
A lot of people don't talk about this.
This is coming from a woman. She says,
male strippers are overrated.
She said,
especially when they are hired
for a Bachelorette party,
is it me or does uh, uh, Jesus Christ,
I can't read when I'm fucking
not hung over. She goes,
is it me or does anyone else think this
is the stupidest waste of 125 bucks
they've ever seen? You guys get
strippers? 425 bucks. Jesus.
Is there anything that sucks about being
a woman? Yeah. Given birth periods.
All right, you're right. You're
right. Sorry. Um, yeah. I can't even,
let me get back to this.
Yeah, the guys are all,
the guys were all muscled up and
everything, but to be honest,
when you see women looking
at male strippers and they
are hooting and hollering
and laughing and laughing it
up with their girlfriends,
they're actually laughing at the stripper.
Yes,
it is true that they are likely some
women who enjoy it and thinking this guy
would probably be awesome in bed,
but 95% of women are hysterically laughing
at the Ridiculous Man All oiled up in
his g string with his stupid little
boombox playing NXS what you need,
Jesus Christ. Yeah, she just, there
you go. She's painting a picture there.
That's what you need and a good story
and you need a narrator who's not fucking
grumpy and hung over anyways,
playing what you need.
Gyrating around the living room
and dry humping. Dad's lazy boy.
You know what? Jesus Christ, uh,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
This is really fucking long. Let me get
to the point here. She says, well women,
what women want is women
want a man who was a man,
kill spiders, drank beer, etc.
None of us would picture a man acting
like a sex machine with a wax chess
dancing in front of a group of housewives.
A man will offer my girl a man will offer.
My girlfriend is a stripper and he knows
his buddies will congratulate them.
Like, God, Dude, you go friends,
a stripper. That's awesome.
A woman would never offer
the same information. Why?
Because she knows the response from other
woman would be a snicker and a yikes.
Gee, I'm so sorry. Look, is that true?
The women really not like
don't just like cougars,
don't they like male strippers?
You know?
If you want to know what it's like
to be a guy, be a woman in your ear.
As far as like our sex drive,
you know,
I think maybe a woman once you're in
your forties at that time I didn't know
what the fuck point I'm
trying to make there.
I just know that like older women
act like the same level of retarded.
That guys act like
our entire fucking wise.
When they start to get older. I don't
know what it is. I guess it's safe.
They finally don't give a shit and they
could admit that they like cock or they
like sex, you know? Because before
they have to be like, well, you know,
it's just for procreation. All
right. Just like my boyfriend's cock,
I don't have any other fucking
fantasies, you know? Whereas guys,
we just get,
we just get to be pigs.
We just get to be the God damn pigs
that we are. But you know what?
You get to cry at movies and get that
shit out and I get to hold it in.
You know what? There was a rough
one was that Harvey milk movie.
The amount of Shit I had to think about
so I wouldn't tear up there in that
movie just so I wouldn't be feeling, you
know, as a guy, you can't fucking cry.
So I got to sit there and be like, you
know, he's, he's going through some shit.
I know everyone was getting all sad when
a, you know, when he gets whacked there,
you know. So in order to not to get
emotional myself, I just thought,
you know what, if someone just came home
and just kicked him right in the balls
and I just started laughing,
you know, that's what it is.
That's what comedy is. It's to
stop from crying. All right?
Um, number two. Oh, this
is, oh my God, this,
some New Yorkers aren't
going to like this one.
This is another thing that she
says is overrated is underrated.
Actually a two run homer
in the bottom of the ninth.
Ninth after Mary off of Marianna Rivera.
And I could've fucking read that better.
Yeah, the red sox swept the Yankees. Man.
This fucking unbelievable. There'll
be back. This shit always happens.
One team always jumps out in front of
the other team. Right? And then we would
do we fucking own you guys.
You good on you good.
And then they literally
almost like it's fixed. Now.
The Yankees will sweep us down there and
we'll play each other like 12 times or
13 times and someone will win
when it fucking seven to six.
It's a God damn business people.
Okay, there's no fucking Santa Claus.
Don't I don't buy it. Um, and we
stole home plate and you know how to,
how the fuck does that happen? $200
million team. You know something.
You realize the red sox sale,
they're only there number four this
year as far as money spent. Oh yeah.
A lot of you fuckers didn't know that.
Did Ya? Yankees spent 200 million,
then it's the mets. Then I believe the
cubs and then us. We're 122 million.
Isn't that great?
Now we can act like where some little
fucking starving panty little Pansy
fucking team
Yaggie did ruin in baseball.
Um, who gives a fuck? I'll tell
you what's funny is of the, the,
the fuck did I just do? There I am.
I sit on my computer. All right,
let's let you know what
I'm really starting to feel
like I'm losing the momentum
of this 31 minutes. 31 hung over minutes.
Dude. I'm going to tell you right now,
this is like four hours. I feel like I'm
doing a fucking telethon right now. Uh,
let's get to the questions for the
week. I got a, I've got one here. Um,
am I the only one who thinks
Terry Francona is glasses?
Make him look like a cancer stricken
Mrs Clause. He's the, he's the,
uh, he's the manager of the red sox.
I did see him. Yeah. Those they,
they're definitely a, yeah, he looks
like he should be at the very least, uh,
you know, going out Carolyn or something
reading the night before Christmas.
I don't fucking know.
I don't know. You know,
I talked a lot about sports last week
and a couple of people really got pissed
just talking about how dumb they are.
Some guy since this,
this huge fucking rant about saying how,
you know,
being into a sports team is
almost as dumb as patriotism.
I know the point you're trying to make.
You know what I mean?
I get it. You know, I know what you're
saying, but you know what the fuck dude.
I mean I've, I've done like
almost two years of these things.
Eventually sports was going to come up
that we always have to talk about what
you want to talk about. This
guy was really, I dunno.
Sometimes I don't know if people are
going for Douche bag of the week.
I don't know what,
do I have anything else here?
I don't think I have anything else. Oh,
Bill, I need some advice. All right,
here's another guy obviously had
some Jamison. Listen to this shit.
This is his question. Hey
Bill, big fan bombed right now.
I didn't get there for a second.
I thought like he said,
big fan and he meant like that line bomb.
But evidently he means he shit faced or
he's the worst speller anywhere in the
world. Here we go. It starts
off. It says, anyways,
I need some objective viewpoint.
Me and this hot chick,
I'm a big old ugly rugby player
recently started hanging out.
He misspelled that and we like, no, he,
he put the e at the beginning of each.
We like each a lot.
Jesus Christ. Dude recently started
hanging out. We like each other a lot.
My problem,
she used to date a black guy.
I have black friends. My buddies
will tear me apart. Thoughts,
advice.
Thanks John.
Well John, um, my thoughts are you're
pretty fucking shit faced when you,
uh,
when you sent that email,
that's my thoughts cause the
rest of it makes no sense.
She used to date a black guy.
Okay, you have black friends.
Is that supposed to establish
that you're not racist?
My buddies will tear me apart.
Like what?
They're going to in a good natured way
rib you that your Dick isn't going to be
as big. I don't know what you're
trying to say here. Tell you what,
why don't you fucking,
you know,
don't email me now cause I know you're
feeling the way I'm feeling, but you know,
sober up. Try to clean that up. You know,
I think maybe you got something there.
Send me a second draft. I
Dunno. What the fuck that means.
She used to date a black guy.
How to fuck would they know
you have black friends? My Body will
tell you where your black friends.
Do they know this guy?
Did she used to date one of the,
one of your friends who's black?
That's just a weird statement.
I have black friends. Do you have
black friends? Sure. We all do.
Like you're trying to loan yourself
some sort of credit credibility.
The fuck does that made anyways?
You know how many friends do I have?
Jody Rosea. He's half Egyptian.
So that takes care of the, uh,
does that take care of Arabs?
Are Egyptians considered era?
I don't know what the fuck Arabs are. I
don't even know. I don't fucking know.
I can't, I know. I don't
know. I don't know.
Is being an innocent one
question I've always is being
Jewish, is that, oh, I know.
It's a religion. Is it a, is it
a race? It's not a race, right?
I don't want to tie,
a long time ago, I, I,
I was in high school and one of
my friends was Jewish, right?
And uh, I said to him, I said,
what are you, what are you Italian?
He goes, no, I'm Jewish. And I,
I could tell I offended them.
So I didn't do a follow up question,
but in my head I'm going, okay,
Italian is a race at the Jewish was a
religion. I know Jewish is a religion.
You know, that doesn't make any fucking
sense. I don't fucking know. Let's,
let's read a revenge story.
That's what he'd revenge story.
And let's fucking wrap up this podcast.
This is going to be a shorter one.
This is the hung over version.
Oh, here's something else.
I came up with this. I'm actually
contributing underrated. You know,
it's underrated. Free Internet and
the hotels got damn. And I liked that.
I wrote all that other shit in anger, so
let's not read that. All right, here's a,
here's a big long revenge story to end
the podcast this week and let me know
about what do you guys
think about this sign?
I know kind of intern in my head a
little bit and I got this mic like
stationaries that affecting the sound
cause God knows I'm not going to go back
and listen to all this shit. I usually
listen to them, but not this week, man.
Not this week. It's been a rough fucking,
we kind of want to tell you, you know,
this is one of these times, so it's
great. I don't have a kid, you know,
because I would have no patience for him.
I know it's a new bit I've been working
on in my act talking about how much I
like, uh, I like kids when they're, I
like kids the same way. Like I like dogs,
I like, I like them when they're
puppies and full of life, you know?
And once they get a little bit older
and stubborn, they think they know shit.
It's just, it's fucking there.
Annoying. You know? I like kids like a,
you're fucking cracks me up.
I saw this kid the other day,
this kid was like two years
old, right. You know, it's
funny about toddlers, right?
How they did I, I talked
about this already. How they
got their little fucking,
they got, they already have a beer
belly and they never even drank daily.
You know, look, these
little fucking truckers,
it always is just fucking makes me
toddlers fucking beer bellies just fucking
make me laugh every time
I say, oh, you know,
it's because they're not self
conscious about their bodies.
They don't give a fuck.
So they just got it hanging out there
like some fucking drunken slob and a
barbecue. You know, they just,
it's just funny to me.
They look like they've already fell.
They fucked up in life. You
know, like they're gambling,
they're eating the wrong food. I don't
know. Why do they have those fat bellies?
Jesus Christ. You're eating mush
in milk. You do you the first,
well,
I just admit,
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking
about sometimes and literally sweating
right now because of a lamp. That's
how fucking hung over. I am. Okay.
Okay. Here we go. You know
something, I'll say, hey, I met,
this is something I've been doing. I've
been, I've been trying to eat, you know,
one just veggie meal a day,
you know,
to then I can make up for the fucking
oxen that I'm going to eat later on that
night or evidently the fucking steak
and shake that I'm going to eat. And uh,
you know, I can't stand about
those fucking veggie meals.
I ordered this Veggie meal,
right? I ordered a, uh, uh,
some sort of fucking horrific Veggie,
a rap,
which really sucked because they
grilled the vegetables. You know,
like when you go beyond where
they start becoming mushy,
it just a, I can't even say what it
sounds like, what it, what it tasted like,
because it's gonna make me fucking
gag here, but you know, it just,
I'm going to do it. You know
what, if you're squeamish,
cover your fucking ears right now. You
know what it tastes like when when you,
they over steam vegetables
or they fucking, uh,
over grill. I don't know what
it gets all squishy and mushy.
It tastes like it's preach.
You'd
just pausing right now waiting for the
groans people throwing their headphones
off.
All you people on elliptical,
talented. You just grown.
Do they have the fat Harry Fuck
next to you. Start looking at you.
Wondering what you're listening
to. Um, there's one I hate.
You're Veggie wrap. All right.
And they go one veggie wrap.
I ordered some soup like an old
fucking Jewish man in Manhattan, right?
And then what happens?
They bring it to me and this,
they got French fries on the side.
It's like, can't you see? I'm trying,
I'm trying to get in shape. I understand
it's a French fries or potato. It's a,
it's a vegetable. I get it. What the fuck?
It's like when you go to
the cheesecake factory,
you order a salad and then they go,
would you like to third? It's like,
do you not get the fucking
theme here lady? Do you not
see what I'm trying to do?
Do you see my bloated
alcohol infused phase?
Do you understand what I'm trying to
do here? I actually, you know what,
it's not even fair cause I actually
talked to one of those a cheesecake,
I think I was making fun of the
cheesecake factory and now my act. And um,
they actually was,
there was a waitress in the crowd as I
always ended up shitting on something.
And then someone from the crowd, it's
like, Hey, I do that. What the fuck?
So it was this cheesecake factory waitress
and she came up to me and she said,
uh, she goes, actually, they
make us do that. We have to
do that. If we don't do it,
we get fired.
Really?
Is that what it's come down to?
Yeah.
That's where the decisions in your life
led you that you have a job that if you
don't ask people for cake, which is
usually a nice fucking thing to do.
If you don't do it,
you get fired.
They have a gun to your fucking head to
basically have your job to try to make
people become diabetics. Is
that what's going on? Yeah.
Is that what happened in your life?
Because you sucked at something in school.
Okay.
You know, I don't fucking know. All
right, let's get on with a revenge story.
I am fucking, I know why I
shut off the air conditioners.
Anybody else just hate air conditioning.
I don't mind air conditioning when it's
9,000 degrees out, but when it's fucking,
you know, it's like, I don't know
what it is. It's like 65 degrees out.
70 72 and they got the air
conditioning on. It's like,
are you trying to give me pneumonia? Huh?
Is that what the fuck you trying to do?
Jesus Christ. Am I in a mood? Hey, what
do you guys think about that? Swine flu?
You know, this might be a
little comfort, controversial,
but I'm kind of all for it.
Yeah.
I think this is another time where
were were getting in the way of nature
running it's course nature
is trying to kill off us.
Not all of us,
but some of us so that you know,
there's no traffic.
You know what I mean?
It's like the forest fire. It's a
rebirth. You know, your burn it down.
Some animals die, some trees die.
You get rid of all the brush.
It's like a spring cleaning. That's all
a plague is. It's just that we, you know,
you don't want any loved ones to
die plagues. And I'll tell you,
man plagues that there are really,
uh, they're fascinating. Like they're,
they're putting out all these stats.
You know what? Fuck this revenge story.
Let me go on the Internet
here. Let me, let me, uh,
let me restart Firefox now. What is your
fucking problem? I never stopped it.
I'm in the middle of a podcast.
Okay.
God Damn, these fucking computers. What
do they do? This shit to me. Come on,
let's go. Anyways, yeah, they were,
they were given up all, all these, uh,
all these statistics on a plagues and
that type of stuff every day. Like,
do you need all that?
Like 675,000 people died in the United
States in 1918 because of like an eye
influenza, whatever the fuck that is.
I ain't know what the fuck that is,
but everybody got it and a whole
bunch of people died, man, you know,
fuck it. You know what's fucked up
about that was thank God they did.
You know, cause if they didn't
they all would've fucked
and they would have made
more fucking people.
You might've been where we're at right
now. We might have been there, you know,
15 years earlier. I love, I
just throw numbers out man.
Like I'm a fucking scientist here or
when I'm talking about, hang on a second,
let's look up plagues.
It's going to get me on some
sort of FBI lists, you know?
Oh I need to do now is
Google fucking anthrax in?
There'll be a knock at my door and I
really will be confessing at this fucking
table here.
Great plagues
in history. Okay. That should
be a great game. Show that,
that'd be a fucking great game.
Show. Okay. Is you try to,
you start googling shit and whoever
gets the FBI to come to your place first
wins and you can't do
like easy shit like uh,
like he obviously any sort of creepy
pedophile stuff cause that's just fucking
horrific and it's,
it's never funny is it?
Even though I joke about it
on stage sometime. All right.
List of historical plagues.
Let's go to Wikipedia.
God knows they're always number one.
Alright.
In human history,
the term plague refers to an epidemic
disease causing a high rate of mortality,
a pestilence and academic dash. Shut
the fuck up. I want to, I want stats.
Okay. What? I've got to go MLB.
You got to go to CBS sports.com.
Is that what I got to go?
Ongoing danger.
Great plagues of Athens.
Let's get to some recent ones here.
You know, what do we got
here? Great plague of Iceland.
See what I'm saying? Everywhere everybody
had a plague and it thin the herd.
Great plague of Portugal, great plague
of Russia. Great Plague of Ireland.
Scotland.
Yeah,
London plague. Just attack the
fucking city for two years.
1592 to 15. 94, the Italian plague,
everybody's fucking had one. It was the
last time we had a plague. You know,
you just say that you just can nip it
in the bud with, with, with fucking,
with the media. They just, they get it
out there before it gets a chance to, to,
to help with the traffic.
You know?
So I'm in New York City right now and
they have a number of a number of cases
out in Queens and uh, you know, they're
telling people how, oh, you know,
it's funny as hell. They tell
people, did you use common sense?
If you feel like you're getting the
flu, go to the hospital. Right? So they,
they say, you know, if you
sneeze or if you cough,
just cover your mouth. Right? So half
hour later, I'm walking down the street,
walking down whatever fucking
avenue here in New York,
and I see this kid on a bicycle and he
proceeds to sneeze and he just turns his
head and it looked like a fucking take.
And I just burst out laughing,
bursting out, laughing. You
know, rather than being,
I'm like the exact opposite of a Yah.
I was going to say a hemophiliac.
That's not what I'm trying to say.
What are those fucking people that
always nervous that they got something,
a hysterectomy? What does it,
I know it begins with an h.
This always happens to me is what happens
to my fucking brain as I knew the word.
And then at my brain panics and
all I'm left with is a letter, uh,
fucking hemophilia.
I can't get that word out of my head,
you know,
and I got to talk about something else.
Let's talk about the Jonas
brothers comedy show. Huh?
I think I speak for the group when
I say it's about time, you know,
because their music is fucking
hilarious. And uh, I, I just, you know,
the fucking cunt is fucking business,
you know what I mean?
Really is, is that, is that what I
should, that's that what I should've done.
I should've gotten this
business with fucking three,
three of my other brothers,
you know, I'll play the drums.
You get a Ukulele and then you do this
and then you'll get your own fucking
sketch show
sons of bitches.
Oh yeah, I am better. I'm better
about the fucking Jonas brothers.
I want some goddamn stats here on dead
people. All right? I don't feel good.
So I wanna read about dead people.
Make all the black death. Here we go.
Here we go.
The black death was one of
the deadliest pandemics.
The fuck is a pandemic is
an epidemic in a pandemic.
A pandemic is an epidemic of infectious
disease that spreads through pop
populations across their large region.
For instance,
a continent or even worldwide.
Thank you, Wikipedia.
So what the fuck is an epidemic
is what happens and you just start
fucking search and everything and then you
figure out what the hell an epidemic
occurs when new cases of a certain disease
occur in a given human
population during a given period.
Isn't that the same fucking thing?
Is that not the same fucking
thing but close enough? All right,
you guys want to hear
about the black death, huh?
When you're sitting there and your
cubicle at work? While, God damn,
and I'm going to read you some shit.
God knows you could do this yourself.
It's right there. And Wikipedia. The
black death was according to chronicles,
characterized by Boobos,
a swelling in the lymph nodes.
I don't even know where the lymph nodes
are. I think there are they in your neck.
A hypochondriac. Bam. I got it. All
right. See, that's what I gotta do.
Just start talking about
all this shit that on.
I know where I yell out the word and
now I can't remember what I was talking
about. Oh, I know. I'm the exact
opposite of a hypochondriac where uh,
no, that doesn't make sense. HYPOCHONDRIAC
is nervous. I had to keep my,
I eat apples.
Scientists and historians at the beginning
of the 20th century assume that the
black death was an outbreak of the same
disease by the bacterium who gives a
fuck and spread by fleas with the help of,
of animals like the black rat.
However,
this view has recently been gimme
some stats for Christ's sake.
How many fucking people died?
What?
Wait, wait a minute. The origins
of the plague. Does that,
did that to Deb deep a debit to the
total number of deaths worldwide is
estimated at 75 million people,
approximately 25 to 50 million
of which occurred in Europe.
The black death is estimated to have
killed 30% to 60% of Europe's population.
Just stick about that people.
Six out of 10 automobiles that you'll see
in front of you tonight as you try and
drive home would not fucking be there.
And we already built the highways
to hold, you know, a ton of fucking
car. You know what I'm saying?
You know it's America, man.
You want to fucking drive,
put the top down and I'm making Pontiac's
anymore. How fucking sad is that?
Let's think about some great Pontiac's.
That's where we're going to close out.
After we talked about the epidemic,
we talked about death.
Let's talk about how sad it is that
there's no more Pontiac's anymore.
There's just no more.
The Pontiac Trans Am eh,
kinda drops off after that.
But you know the sun bird,
the t 1000 you guys remember the Pontiac
t 1000 as when you're really fucked up.
When you bought a bootleg Chevette.
That's when you really were saying that
you were an extra level of white trash.
Okay? You ate macaroni and
cheese five times a fucking week,
you know?
You know I can't even,
what the Fuck I've even said today
that I was, I riffing about Sharon,
a tray of macaroni cheese with
another man looking into his eyes.
Was that this podcast?
Was that another podcast?
Was that at some point a show last night?
I don't know what,
but this has been the Monday morning
podcast for a April fucking 20 something.
I don't know what it is.
I don't know. This is,
we're into garbage time.
They still have their as well.
Their official site is still up.
When I went to a party x or they
have the Bonneville. You know what?
They were a one trick pony.
Anybody drive a Pontiac?
I don't know. Well, let's talk
about that next week. Okay.
This is the Monday morning podcast,
Mba Caroline's this week.
And then I'm taking a break
here for a May and June,
going to recharge my fucking batteries
and I'm coming out swinging in July.
I started the comedy works in Denver,
and then I go do a Eddie's
fist fuck in a fucking a Uma.
I'm just gonna make up shit now.
And then I'm going to be at a wallpaper.
Freddy's at the limelight.
Um,
beautiful theater. We're a
Cirque de Solei performed.
Just reading the awful brochures here.
What is Cirque de Solei?
I'm really impressed with the,
the strength that those guys have.
Not so much on the costumes.
All right, you guys, that's
the podcast for this week.
I hope you guys all
have a tremendous week.
And I apologize if I was a little bit
grumpy this week, but, uh, you know,
I'm sorry. All right, that's on me. I'm
just going to palm. Sorry. All right.